vaccines or as the fun doctor and your
family practice books it shot-shot
shot-shot shot-shot shot-shot church
seriously there'll be a slight pinch
now vaccines are one of humanity's most
incredible accomplishments and they've
saved millions of lives and there was a
time when a new one was a cause for huge
celebration dr. Jonas Salk discovers a
vaccine that promises to wipe out
childhoods crippling and killing enemy
polio anxious parents are thrilled and
grateful responding to one of the
greatest mass inoculations and medical
annals it's true people lined up for the
polio shot like it was an iPhone
although although for the record polio
was never childhoods most crippling
enemy because that was and will forever
remain accidentally seeing your father's
penis
but suffice it by their success small
groups are both skeptical and vocal
about vaccines which is nothing new but
these days their voice has been
amplified by the human megaphone that is
the President of the United States I am
totally in favor of vaccines but I want
smaller doses over a longer period of
time because you take a baby in and I've
seen it and I've seen it and I had my
children taking care of over a long
period of time over two or three year
period of time same exact amount but you
take this little beautiful baby and you
pump I mean it looks just like it's
meant for a horse not for a child that
is totaled from on the campaign trail
raising doubts about vaccinations and
that is a sentiment that he's also
expressed online with a tweet reading
tiny children are not horses and that
that is an assertion that PolitiFact
rates yeah I mean I guess technically
we've got to give him that but you agree
and look look you know this you know
this it is not wise to take health care
advice from man who has willingly sought
care from this doctor who looks like he
sneaks into a sin you're frogs in the
middle of the night to Fox the boxer
elastics you let you know that but but
it is not just Trump who is skeptical
and those concerns have driven some
people to extremes for instance back in
2011 some parents made headlines by
taking what they saw are they more
natural route to immunizing their
children Catherine were talking about
parents who are taking use the lollipops
saliva and puss soaked clothing from
complete strangers and deliberately
infecting their children okay okay all
right so setting aside the grossest of
parents infecting their kids with
lollipops from strangers that graphic
has an unfortunate misspelling because
swapping spit and passing pulse
sounds like the TED talk that Kid Rock
would give you a teenage shot
what's wrong I know you're going to want
to swap some straight past the hood but
if you don't throw a raincoat on that
devil dog it's going to be stored silly
for you buckaroo this was quality time
we just had some quality time and while
it is important to remember that the
vast majority of parents are making sure
that their children get vaccinated on
time the voices of those who don't carry
any internet search about vaccines will
quickly lead you down a frightening
rabbit hole and the background hum of
doubt can make some parents
understandably nervous I'm concerned
about how many vaccines you need
remember we have to give our children at
once some kind of debating whether I
will do them but I'm debating the age
when should I have them done there's
just so much information there I don't I
don't know who to ask I don't know if
there's you know there's no such thing
as an unbiased source at least 10
percent of parents delay or skip some
shots around 1 percent don't vaccinate
at all right you know parents get so
much information it is hard to know what
to do should you vaccinate should you
eat the placenta should you let kids cry
and the answer to those by the way are
yes no and absolutely because the more
they try now the more they'll be
prepared to watch this is us when they
get older
[Applause]
and this this atmosphere of confusion
about vaccines has caused real problems
there are now 11 states where the number
of unvaccinated kids is on the rise and
in small pockets all over America the
numbers can get startlingly high in the
Somali community in Minnesota the
measles vaccination rate for children
dropped to just 42 percent and that had
some very real consequences measles once
eradicated in the u.s. is now exploding
in Minnesota Somali community where many
parents won't vaccinate the virus is so
contagious that if you're exposed to it
and you don't have the vaccine there's a
90% chance you'll contract it they can
have permanent brain damage they can
have blindness or deafness and so we
wouldn't vaccinate if this was just a
Raschi illness this is a very serious
disease exactly and this is how bad it
is in that community the number of
measles cases so far this year has
already outpaced the total number in all
the US last year and that is terrible
because the only thing Minnesota should
have more of than any other state is
Garrison Keillor and people disappointed
by the Mall of America
oh so it's just a bigger mall and it has
to build-a-bear workshops that's amazing
this memory will last me a lifetime
as will these two bears for two
different build-a-bear workshop so
tonight we are going to look at why
these beers persist and what the
consequences of succumbing to them can
be and before we start I kind of get why
vaccines can creep people out
vaccinations can mean getting injected
by a needle filled with science juice
although pretty much every medical
practice sounds terrifying when you
break it down like that an appendectomy
means removing one of your organs
through stabber II antibiotics are
poisons used to murder things living in
you and even exercise means forcefully
burning up your inside
my point is the human body is a true
Carnival of Horrors and frankly I'm
embarrassed to have one
and what much of the fear surrounding
vaccines stems from their supposedly to
autism now that is a theory that gained
traction in the late 90s thanks to a
study published in the medical journal
The Lancet suggesting a link between
autism and the MMR vaccine the study was
of just 12 children and it was by this
guy Andrew Wakefield and if you're
wondering why I didn't say dr. Andrew
Wakefield this is why follow-up studies
of hundreds of thousands of children
could not find any evidence that the MMR
vaccine causes autism and investigations
into Wakefield's original paper revealed
he distorted the data and acted
unethically
he's lost his medical license The Lancet
paper has been retracted
it's true Wakefield's made a big splash
before having his legacy tarnished and
his title revoked he's basically the
Lance Armstrong of doctors but but but
even though Wakefield conclusions have
been debunked many times he not only
denies wrongdoing he actually still
gives talks about the supposed dangers
of the MMR vaccine in fact this is him
in 2011 talking to the Somali community
that we saw earlier in Minnesota and
presumably ending his speech with trust
me I'm a used to be a doctor and to be
fair Wakefield is not the only voice
raising alarms about vaccines he has
company from across the political
spectrum from a Robert F Kennedy jr. on
the left to Alex Jones wherever the
he fits in to even this guy he can't
make you can't make people do procedure
that they don't want the parents have to
be the ones to make the decisions for
what's best for Mike for our kids it
can't be the government saying that it's
against the nuremberg laws yes that is
Rob Schneider performing an impromptu
rendition of his famous character the
annoying guy who is wrong because
because despite his misunderstanding of
among other things what the Nuremberg
Laws are and what constitutes acceptable
headwear for a grown man Snyder has
spoken out against mandatory vaccines
for years even once calling this
California state Assemblywoman to debate
the issue prompting her to post on
Facebook
be honest that is 20 minutes of my life
I'll never get back
arguing that vaccines don't cause autism
with deuce Bigalow male gigolo yeah sure
so it's funny it's funny but so hold on
lady let's not Sully the good name of
deuce Bigalow just because of something
that his portrayal Rob Schneider said
that's like implying William Wallace
doesn't trust Jews or officer Nordberg
is a murderer so no time separate the
two now now the good news is these days
very few people will say they are
completely anti-vaccine instead like the
president they'll say I'm not anti
vaccine but and it's what comes after
that but that we need to look at tonight
because one example is hey I'm not anti
vaccine but I am Pro safe vaccine and
and that can often refer to concern over
scary sounding ingredients like
thimerosal a mercury-based preservative
for years now RFK jr. has led a crusade
against it in fact just this year he
gave a speech where he said this for 33
years I've been working to get mercury
at fish nobody has ever called me any
fish and because I want mercury out of
vaccines I should not be called any
vaccine okay well for a start what would
anyone be ashamed to be called anti fish
fish are stupid and how do I know that
look at them just look at this idiot and
it's not just him check this out
as well and while you're at it what
about this dimwit here's another
bonehead for you I'm pretty sure this
dunks didn't make it past the third
grade
and I think we can all agree that this
doofus isn't exactly curing cancer oh
that's right
come at me fish oh I'm sorry you can't
kanya because because and that's because
after 500 million years you still
haven't figured out how to breathe air
you fish it's easy
I'm doing it now
even you don't know me fish get out of
here
you know what more importantly in
fact much more importantly it is worth
knowing that the mercury that has been
used in vaccines is not the same kind
that is harmful in fish on top of which
as with the MMR vaccine there have been
multiple large studies finding no link
between thimerosal and autism and
perhaps most importantly at all since
the early 2000s as a precautionary
measure it has been removed as a
preservative from all vaccines
recommended for infants except for the
flu vaccines and even there thimerosal
three versions are available so we
essentially spent time and energy
solving a problem that never existed
it's like spending years fighting to get
marshmallows out of Lucky Charms because
a few people think minions can choke to
death on them force our marshmallows
dissolve and minions don't exist and if
they did I would want them to choke to
death because those little will
murder us open your eyes and look if
you're thinking well hold on hold on if
it wasn't harmful why was it taken out
well there was intense public concern
that was amplified by people like then
congressman Dan Burton making arguments
like this I have not yet to find any
scientist who will say that there's no
doubt no doubt that the mercury in
vaccines does not contribute to autism
now they'll say there's no scientific
evidence there's no studies or anything
that proves that yet but turn that
around there are no studies that
disprove it either all right all right
okay
proving a negative is an impossible
standard and that is also a slippery
slope because it means that I can say to
you you Dan Burton are a donkey
you dress up donkeys in cheerleader
outfits and you thought them if what
you're into and you do it all
and you are saying to me for weight
there is absolutely no evidence of me
doing that but I would say turn that
around there's no evidence of you not
doing that either please and this is not
a road that you want to go down and the
thing is the thing is that donkey
is remarks actually get at why
scientists can be at a real disadvantage
in this debate because they by their
nature are careful in how they present
their conclusions science and English
are not really the same language and so
when a scientist says we have no
evidence that there's a link between
vaccines and autism what they're really
saying is you know we are as positive as
someone can humanly be that there's no
link and one thing that I sometimes do
when I'm talking to parents is say I'm
as confident that there's no link
between vaccines and autism as I am that
if I was going to walk off this building
that I would not be able to fly right
and that is about as clear as you can be
and for the record if your doctor does
believe they can fly run because they
are either crazy or they are are Kelly
and if your if your pediatrician is are
Kelly that things are actually the least
of your problem and I know I know that
some will say that the real problem is
that scientists have been paid by pharma
companies to hide the problems with
vaccines you can find countless memes
online about how the whole system is
corrupt some of which feature a very
smart looking cat and and I'm not saying
that there are not problems with Big
Pharma there absolutely are we have
discussed them before on this show but
on the rare occasions where there have
been issues with vaccines they have been
pulled and fast and I know that that
explanation will still not satisfy some
there are going to be some truly toxic
comments below this video
alongside the usual ones about how I
look like an owl who can't get a date
for prom
Oh or that I probably live alone
surrounded by jars I'm too weak to open
by myself and I think you're laughing
too hard at that and those comments will
link to the hidden truths about vaccines
and demand to know why I didn't look
into them and you know what we did look
into a lot of them and the problem is I
can go point by point by point and be
talking for hours tonight and this will
still never end it's like whack-a-mole
as one theory goes down another pops up
and I kind of get the insistence that
there must be a link at the age children
are supposed to get the MMR vaccine
happens to be the same age that
diagnosable signs of autism can begin to
appear but correlation is not causation
that is what scientific studies are for
and remember they are really clear that
link is not there and the problem with
spending more and more time and money
trying to prove that link is that it
takes resources away from studying
actual causes and treatments just listen
to the mother of one child with autism
who started a foundation precisely
because she wanted to find out the
causes we have dozens of studies I think
we were right to look at whether
vaccines might be a cause of autism but
there comes a point where there is so
much evidence none of which shows any
link between vaccines and autism that
you have to say enough yeah that's right
it's like that Einstein quotes is
sometimes see on the Internet the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over again and expecting
different results
except Einstein didn't say that because
and it seems I cannot stress this enough
means aren't fact and if you won't take
that from me take it from this very
smart looking cat
but again that that hyung of doubt it's
hard to shake off and some parents agree
with the president and they favor
hedging their bets and skipping or
spacing vaccines out just in case
93% of pediatricians say they've been
asked by parents to do just that and one
of the places that that idea may be
coming from is a pediatrician named dr.
Sears not bill sees the famous doctor
and author but his son Bob Sears dr. Bob
has made a name for himself with what
can seem like a sensible sounding
approach to address wide parents
concerns what I've put together is what
I call my alternative vaccine schedule
it's a way to get a baby fully
vaccinated that in a manner that spreads
the shots out a little bit and that
sounds like a decent compromise because
it's the middle ground position right
the problem is is the middle ground
between sense and nonsense
it's like saying it would be crazy to
eat that entire bar of soap
so I'll just eat half of it now the
enthusiasm for spacing vaccines out
stems from some parents belief that
children these days get too many shots
too soon perhaps best summed up by this
meme of a dog full of needles and I will
say if that's how they were given I
would oppose that but let's break that
fear down because while it is true that
children do receive more shots than they
used to the number of antigens in those
shots or the substances that induce the
immune response has greatly decreased
and it's a drop in the ocean compared to
the thousands of foreign antigens our
child usually encounters every day just
watch a child for five minutes and see
if they don't eat their friend's boogers
put their entire mouth over the water
Balcon or try and kiss a raccoon they
just found in a dumpster while playing
hide and seek my point is children are
disgusting
I even see it himself as of may be that
his approach is not based on scientific
research so where is that where is the
published peer-reviewed evidence to
support the notion of a quote overload
if you follow the CDC recommended
schedule where where does that exist
Chris I don't think there is any such
research and I actually never claimed
there was I certainly have put out there
very clearly in my writings that my
precautions on spreading out vaccines
are theoretical it's a theoretical
benefit to kids and it's a choice that I
think a lot of parents feel more
comfortable about and might actually
bring more parents to vaccinate if they
can spread the shots out more than the
regular schedule right except your job
is to make sure children don't get
deadly diseases not to make parents
comfortable because you're a
pediatrician not a flask of whiskey
tucked into a BabyBjorn dr. Bob
sometimes seems to be trying to have it
both ways because while he says he is
pro-vaccine and that he doesn't
explicitly tell parents to skip or delay
important shots his book just happens to
include an alternative vaccine schedule
and a selective vaccine schedule and on
that one you can get vaccinated for
measles as late as ten years old and on
top of that every once in a while he'll
drop a line like this you may may
statement I like to make on vaccine
there and autism is that vaccines don't
cause autism
except when they do and I know that
sounds like equivocating but
don't worry
opportunistic quacks writing books that
fanned the flames of people's unfounded
fears don't cause a legitimate public
health hazard except when they do
and what the benefits of dr. Sears in
plan are as he says theoretical the
dangers of spacing vaccines out are very
real the CDC says spreading shots out
puts children at risk of developing
diseases during the time that shots are
delayed and some of those diseases are
dangerous
measles alone was responsible for over a
hundred and thirty thousand deaths
worldwide in 2015 partly because it is
ridiculously infectious I'm talking
happy' by pharrell infectious I just
said that and it's already stuck in your
head now I'm happy there you go that's
how infectious measles is and one way we
can keep needles at bay is through
something called herd immunity that is
the concept whereby the more people who
are vaccinated the harder it is for a
disease to spread but the margin for
safety there is a lot smaller than you
may think
most experts say that the herd immunity
threshold for measles is around 95% but
when in France that dropped to 89% a few
years back this is what happened in 2007
there were around 40 cases of measles
across France then in 2008 a
ten-year-old girl returned from holiday
in Austria she went back to school and
played with some friends
several days later the girls became ill
the measles infection spread from
district to district inspecting the
susceptible population in 2011 there
were almost 15,000 cases at least six
people died okay so that clip proves two
things to us one a decrease in herd
immunity can have devastating
consequences and to anything is
terrifying if you play children's
singing frère Jacques underneath I
guarantee you that true just look at
what happens when you add that music
underneath this stock footage that we
found there is no way that those kids
are not about to be decapitated by a
stock pile no way if you're thinking
well you know that that is a chance I'm
willing to take it and I'm just making
this choice for my child
the thing is you're not you're putting
at risk kids like Rhett Crouch he was
diagnosed with leukemia at age two and
his immune system was weakened so much
he couldn't be vaccinated meaning if he
picked up a serious disease it could be
fatal and I'll let his mom take it from
here when he was first diagnosed he was
pretty much pulled out of society we
avoided highly concentrated groups of
people when we went out we were masks I
mean we really did limit his exposure
and we just were so excited for the day
when he could start kindergarten so he
could have that sense of socialization
and community and learning a year into
remission and back in school Rhett will
soon be healthy enough to be fully
vaccinated but until then his life
depends on herd immunity
exactly so by getting vaccinated you're
helping and protecting those who are
most vulnerable like sick people
and newborns too young to be vaccinated
and why would you choose not to do that
I believe Jesus Christ himself put it
best when he said do you seriously need
some sort of wise quote to convince you
on this one
just like don't be a dick and look I
know I honestly know but for some people
this is still hard but but what can help
is to try and anchor yourself to what we
know to be true about the risks of
vaccines and when it comes to autism
again there is no link and even when it
comes to other serious side effects like
a severe allergic reaction it is
literally according to the CDC close to
one in a million and I know that in a
way that's not actually helpful because
every parent thinks their child is one
in a million but if it makes you feel
better your child's odds of being
convicted of murder and eventually
executed by the state are only one in a
hundred and nineteen thousand and twelve
yes and if that makes you feel even
worse just cheer up maybe your child
will be one of those murderers that
never gets course maybe they're very
smart clearly and you know maybe one of
the biggest problems here is that when
people hear about vaccines so much of
the emphasis is on non-existence or
wildly unlikely harms and and we tend
not to talk about the very tangible good
that they do after all nobody is going
on facebook to post didn't get polio
again today
so less and maybe we kind of should
because it is easy to forget the
benefits of vaccines are enormous what
we have seen in the industrialized world
is essentially all of the major
epidemics they've vanished mums today
have every expectation that their
beautiful little baby will live and not
be polished off by de faria by Tiffany's
even occasionally by meals now that is
the transformation in young lives that
vaccines are brought and that is a
really good point
only slightly undercut by him using the
phrase polished off because it's talking
about babies not a rack of ribs here's
the thing it really comes down to this
it is likely done at some point you may
hear scary vaccine stories from other
parents or on the internet and it is
hard not to be terrified
when you encounter it and that is partly
because Parenthood in general is
terrifying
believe me I'm someone who is scared of
literally everything the dark the light
Heights depths confined spaces wide open
spaces strangers intimacy spiders and a
sudden and mysterious lack of spiders
but all of that but for what is wrong
and if this helps at all I have a son he
is 19 months old he was born prematurely
following a very difficult pregnancy and
I've worried about his health and I'm
still worried about it helped a lot but
we are vaccinating him fully on schedule
and if I can overcome the temptation to
listen to the electoral shouting of my
terrified lizard brain then I believe
that everyone can